Kovach 19 is spreading rapidly
throughout the world the US has reported
over 5,000 cases so far with many states
practicing social distancing to limit
the spread of the virus the Centers for
Disease Control and Prevention's say
that kovat 19 is spread primarily
through person-to-person contact from
something like a cough or a sneeze but
even if you're not in direct contact
with someone who is contagious you might
still come in contact with the virus
if someone coughs or sneezes into their
hands or wipes their nose and then
touches a surface it could become
contaminated the CDC says this type of
transmission has not been documented but
experts say contaminated surfaces can
still pose a risk new research from the
National Institutes of Health Princeton
University and the University of
California Los Angeles broke down how
long the kovat 19 virus can survive on
different surfaces and while these
results could be affected by temperature
humidity UV light and wind it's a
reminder of how easily the virus can
spread
luckily the virus isn't airborne but it
can linger in droplets on particles in
the air the study found that viruses
could last up to three hours and
droplets in the air maintaining a
distance of six feet from other people
can help avoid particles spread through
a call for a sneeze on copper surfaces
like a drawer handle the virus can last
up to four hours while researchers found
that the virus can survive on cardboard
for up to 24 hours
the CDC believes packages or mail are
unlikely to transmit the virus
Cobin 19 appears to last the longest on
plastic and stainless steel two to three
days that's longer than the flu can live
on surfaces according to the CDC
non-porous surfaces seem to allow the
virus to survive longer that could
include things like doorknobs bus and
subway handrails light switches desks
and keyboards we don't know how long the
virus can live on a phone or a phone
case but researchers speculate that
because it's a smooth non absorbent
surface it's possible that the
survivability would be similar to
plastic there are several steps you can
take to reduce your risk of exposure
always avoid touching your eyes mouth
and face and wash your hands with soap
and water for at least 20 seconds if
you're not able to wash your hands use
hand sanitizer
you should also routinely clean commonly
used surfaces like doorknobs and your
phone with disinfecting wipes and avoid
non-essential travel to public places
especially at peak times
you